よろしくお願いします
えーと まあなんかエピソードがあります
ずいぶん長いエピソードが
えーと 皆さんはとっくにご存知だと思いますけど
これが なんかずいぶん信じ難いというかね
エピソードなんですけど
それと今日の偈文は まあこのエピソードとほとんど関係ないエピソードを積めてますから
ダンパダでは この この大阿羅漢方の中で
このマハーカッチャーヤナという阿羅漢
カッチャーヤナ 日本でもよく知っている化洗
何とかという風に漢訳していますけどね
先週の数字のリストには入っているんです
この長老 大阿羅漢がこのソーリヤという地方で托鉢に出かけようと思って
この大体村に入ろうとする時は
きちんと衣を着て整えて入るんです
森の中にいるとか 別にそんなに
大体衣っていうのは大事にしなくちゃいけないんだから
上の衣とかそれを置いておいて
いるんです それを持って村に入る前に
外で人がないところですけどね
そこで衣をちゃんとセキタリに沿って着て入ります
このソーリヤ村のある
裕福な家庭の人が その時は村
町を出て外 彼も外の方にいたんですね
それでこのマハーカッチャーヤナ長老が
あの衣を着ているところは見たんですね
マハーカッチャーヤナ阿羅漢のこの体を見てしまったんですね
それでこのマハーカッチャーヤナ長老っていうのは
このかなりのすごい美男の方で
その美しさは男性としてね
すごい それなりに結構話題にはなっていたんですね
かなり美しい体を持っている人やと
でもまあ衣を着ているんだからね
そんな体見えるわけじゃないし
この人はもう このちゃんと衣を着ようと思って
衣をただ手で持って行って
そこでもう着るでしょうと思いますけど
その時体見て なんて綺麗な体でしょうかと
ものすごくこの驚いてしまったんです
あまりにも感動してこういうことを思ったみたいんですね
この長老が私のお姫さんになれば
何ということでしょうかと
あるいは自分のお姫さんにも
こんな体があれば なんてすごいことでしょうかと
ものすごく思ってしまったんですね
そこを思った瞬間で 彼がどうなったかというと
彼の男性的なところはたちまち消えてしまって
女になってしまったと
[笑い]彼がもういきなり自分の体が性的に変換してしまったんだからね
あまりにも恥ずかしくて
そのまま逃げてしまったみたいです
かなり豊かな人でしたけど
みんなとなんかこの用事があって家を出たみたいですけどね
それで彼がそのまま別なタックスラという
今もタクシーラというところ
地方にありますけどね
昔からその名前変わってないんです
で そちらの方に出て行ったんです
で それからもうこの人
家の人々やらみんなもう人を探すんですね
どこに行ったかともう家の主人はと
どこを探しても見つからないんです
それでも家の人々はもう亡くなったでしょうと待っていて
待っていて 帰ってこないし
亡くなったでしょうと思って
葬式やらね そういうものをやってしまったと
彼が出て逃げて行って
タクシーラというところに
そちらの方が行った方が結構遠いところで
そこへ行った方がいいなと言ったら道がわからない
それでタクシーラの方に商売に行く車のグループを見つけて
そこを後ろから一緒に行けばいいということで出て行ったんです
そこでいても このもうカラバンの人々はね
なんか女の人はもう車の後ろから来るんですけど
もうどちらの女性かわからないんだから
一応聞いてみましょうと言ったら
もう女だからね 彼女はね
私のことを構わず あなた方は行ってくださいと
私も一応後ろから行きますよと
歩いて そこでは女になったその人が
やっぱり身の安全のためでもありますから
みんなもうそれいいということで一緒に行って
そこでまあもう何ヶ月かもかかる旅だからね
この人々はこう考えたんですね
このタクシーラの彼ら商売しているこの商人にはね
まだ結婚していないんだと
で 彼に言っておきましょうと
結構綺麗な女性がいるんだということを
で これまた商売的に考えたんですね
旦那さんにこのお嫁さんにふさわしい人を連れてきたんだよということにしましょうと
この商人の人も彼女を見てね
気に入って自分の家に入れてもらったんです
まあまあまあ注釈書で余計なことをいろいろ書いてますけどね
そんなことはあまり珍しいと思う必要もないんだと
男っていうのは女になったらもう誰でもいいと思いますよと
女も男なら誰でもいいと思いますよと
この二人は二人がいつでもそんなもんやと
だから男たちっていうのは女なら誰でもいいやと思って
他人の人も人の奥さんですか
人妻にしても ものすごい欲を抱いたりして
これで悪い不倫を犯したりして
結局地獄に落ちるんだよと
ただ 男から見れば女ならもう誰でもいいやという感じですから
もうこれ人妻だってそれ気にしないんですね
そういうことだから 罪を犯したりして地獄に落ちるんだと
そこで そういうことをして地獄に落ちる人々は
また やがて人間として生まれ変わりますからね
かなり時間経っても 人間として生まれ変わっても
結局は女で生まれちゃいますと
これアナンダ尊者も昔そういう出来事あったと
かなり過去生で あのもうお釈迦様のお世話をするような
その資格を得るために
パーラミティパーラミタという修行を完成していたのに
あるある生まれ出生まれの時はこの普通のこの何といいますか
鍛冶屋 鍛冶屋の家で生まれて
人の奥さんとなんか一緒になっちゃって
で そのでまた地獄に落ちちゃって
パーラミタ完成している間と言ったっても
悪いことしたらもう地獄落ちちゃうんです
それで地獄で苦しんで
また人間に生まれ変わったりしてね
それで 4 14回も女として生まれたことがあるんだと
このアナンダ尊者さえも
それで 7回 男で生まれたんですけど
何かわけ なんて何でしたっけ？男性の場合は
あれ中国でもやりますでしょう
なんて言いますか あれはやっていたでしょう
睾丸って言うんですか？睾丸
それは取られてしまったと
え？ それは去勢ですか
去勢だ で だからこれ何よというかというと
この 14回ももう男に女で生まれたということと
また 7回もまた生まれ変わって生まれ変わって
また去勢されてしまっちゃったというね
やっぱりこれいい加減なことするなよということは
これですごい注意を入れているところなんですね
本来はもうそんなもんやと
だからそれもまた自然で男なら女だったら誰でもいいやという感じでいるし
女も男なら誰でもいいやという感じでいるし
だからものすごい不自然な行為
出来事っていうのはいくらでも起きますし
年は気にしないわ 親戚関係は気にしないわ
人妻はと気にしないわ
法律は気にしないわ もうそういう風にこの欲っていうのは大変な恐ろしいものであると
あるんで それをすごい不自然なことであると認めた上で
絶対やるなよと だからこの
今のこの今の知識社会で思っているような
このとんでもないことやとか
そういう 何といいますか
すごい厳しい態度をとってないんです
性的なことにしたっても
いろんな人間はいろんな好みを持っていて
それでものすごい社会はそれを批判したりするんですね
で 批判したりするし 社会から追い出したりもするし
そうやってもう激しい差別いじめに遭うんですよ
で まあヨーロッパの方も
特に同性愛っていうのはものすごいもうなんかその方が一番たくさんいるみたいな感じですからね
で なんかものすごい不自然でありえないもの
もう神に神を侮辱しているんだという
もうホームページいっぱいありますよ
もうもうこんな英語を使うべきかというほどの
ものすごいきつい言葉でもう貶したり
もうもう 侮辱したりとかね
もうかなりの運動までやって
そんな差別っていうのは仏教ではないんです
だから仏教はいつでもちょっと非難されたり
バカにされたりもします
別にそんなのはごく普通であると
ごくごく普通の当たり前のことですけど
道徳は道徳で道徳的なこと
これをやっちゃうとひどい目に遭いますよと
まあ人の女性見たら気に入るっていうことは
これは人間の心欲があるんだから
まあそれはごく simple 簡単な自然な法則であって
だからといってやってはいいわけじゃないんだという
だから人を差別することは
ものすごい丁寧に すごい厳密に
そこはまあ抜かしているんですね
まあそういうことで この
こういうことを書いているんです
そこで男はこの悪いことをしちゃうと女になりますけど
だから女はどうなりましょうかと
女は悪いことすると男になると言っちゃうと理屈は崩れちゃうんですね
まあとにかくまあこの性的な関係では
まあやっぱり男は有利というか
すごい気楽というかね
だからそれは仏教は知りません
それは世間のことだからね
苦労するのはいつでも女性の方なんです
ですから 初めからも女性はハンディを持っているんだという態度を取っているんです
で どう見ても子供育てなくちゃいけないし
そうすると 1箇所に身を下ろしておかなくちゃいけないし
で そうなってくると他人から養ってもらわなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうし
他人が養ってくると もう他人のお世話を必死でやらなくちゃいけないという
このまあ主婦業っていうのは
やっぱり自然法則にも成り立っているんですね
それで それ自然法則に成り立っているんだからといって
どう見てもハンディなんですね
平等にはならないんですね
男はいつでも有利な立場でいるんだと
ということは 業でいえば
やっぱりなんか楽をする業をやってるんではないかという理屈になるんです
だから 業が悪ければ楽はできないし
業が良ければ楽をできるし
まあそういう理屈で まあ良いことをしてするんだから男になったと
それは言ってないんですけど
あの なんとなくそういうふうに
この そういう方向 方向で書いてはやるんです
なぜかというと 女性が不倫したらどうなるのかという問題を解決しなくちゃいけないんです
男が不倫しちゃうと地獄に落ちて苦しんで
また生まれ変わったっても女になって
またその苦労 女の苦労を味わってみて
それからまたもうあの去勢されたりすると
もうものすごい惨めな生き方をしなくちゃいけない
そういう大変なひどい目に遭いますよと
言うなれば まあだから女性
どうすればそこが書いてないんですね
女性が不倫すればどうなるのかと
だからここら辺は まあこれはブッダゴーサ朝の注釈時代の考え方だから
別にお釈迦様の考え方というわけでもなりません
注釈書になってくると
そういう 注釈書ではこう書いてるんですね
女性っていうのはよく徳を積んだりするんだと
善行為をしたり まあすごい真面目に戒律を守ったり
良いことをしたり よく頑張っているんだと
そうやって女ほど悪いことをしないんだという意味なんですね
比べてみると 女性の方がよく善行為するのは女性の方がよくいっぱいやってるんだと
だったら何か特権なければあかんんですけどね
こういうものは書いてないんですね
おそらく言いたがっているのは
女性が昔からやっぱり自分たちが社会で平等じゃないというね
それはよく痛感しているんですね
昔はものすごい厳しい男女差別はありましたから
いくら厳しいイスラム文化だったらもう最悪ですけど
それでもそれで喜んでいる女もいるんだからね
もう顔も隠して何にも隠して
ただ品物扱いされてよかったと
でもそれには反対する女もいるし
反対したら殺されますから
ただ嫌な気持ち持っているだけで
それはインド文化にしたっても
やっぱり女性はいろいろ苦労しなくちゃいけないというね
その不公平というかね
その気持ちは女性はずっと感じているんですね
感じているんですけども
どうしようもないんですね
解決方法もない どうやって平等にするのかというと
これはもう決してできることではないんです
どうしても子供を産んで育てなくちゃいかないんです
で まあそういうことだから
まあだから女性たちはこのこんな平等でもない
この惨めな生き方 嫌やと
その気持ちもあって 男になればいいやと思って
まあ毎日のように良いことをしているんだから
彼女たちは生まれ変わったらもう何のことなく
しっかりと男で生まれ変わるんだと
あるいはまあ別に善行為とか修行とか
そういうことがなくても
自分の女性としての家庭を守ることやら子育てやらね
それは随分丁寧に真剣にやっておくと
それは結構良い善行為になるんだと
そういうことをやってても
もう金輪際はおんなは嫌やと思ってしまうと
まあ男で生まれるんだと
で 男で生まれたらまた不倫してまた
まあどちらがということは書いてないんですけどね
なんでこういうこういう女性論を書いたかというと
このストーリー書いてるブッダゴーサ長老も
このストーリーはどうかなと思っていたでしょうと思いますよ
立派な男がもう瞬時に性転換というんですか
その場合は まあゆっくりゆっくりじわじわと変わっていくならばね
それはもうなんとなく理解できますけどね
例えばこの遺伝子が変わってしまって
遺伝子が変わると まあゆっくりとじわじわと変わる可能性もあるし
あるいはまあホルモンがなくなったりとかね
もう男性ホルモンがなくなって
その代わりに女性ホルモンが生まれ出して
両方持っているんだから
みんな男も女も だからそういう風に何かホルモンがバランス崩れちゃってというならばね
まあこれそれでもゆっくりだからね
たちまちまあ瞬時ということは
ちょっとどう考えてもちょっとどうかなと
しかしまああるストーリーだから
仏教徒にしたってもね
そのストーリーは好き勝手に変えることはできません
だからちょっと間に説法でも入れてやろうかなとかいうことでしたんではないかなと思います
それでこの性別はこの一応生命にはあることなんですよ
ずっと で あの これは心の状態なんですね
心の感情の問題で この煩悩のせいで
まあそこで好き嫌いが生まれますから
別に理屈あるわけじゃないんです
だから何かを好きになる
何かを嫌いになるという
この好き嫌い衝動っていうのは全ての生命にはあります
あるんだけど 人間だからこれこれ好きですよという普遍的な法律
決まりはないんです で
これが変わっちゃうんですよ
例えば犬は犬だから このきゅうり
塩漬けのきゅうりやらね
おしんこやらもうパクパクと食べる
お前犬でしょ？と言いたいんだけど
もう聞かないんですね
奪って食べる 普通考えちゃうと
もうもう魚とか肉とか食べるんですけど
もう教えてあげればご飯も食べる場合もありますけど
まあきゅうりまで もう確かにいるんですよ
だからこの何が好きになるかっていうことは
もうそんなもうわからないんですよ
もうパパイヤ好きな犬はいるし
で あの熱海にいたあの亡くなったあのシロちゃんがね
猫がね これがメロンが好きで
メロンが見るとよだれが出るんですよ
どういうことかと ご飯なんかは食べない
もう肉やらもう魚やらね
あるいは猫の餌やら そういうものしか食べないんだけど
メロン見るともうこちらからもう垂らしちゃうんですね
ですから この垂れて何やとわからないんですよ
別に猫の舌っていうのは味がそんなにわかる舌じゃないんですよ
メロンは甘いんだからなんとかとかって
それは人間の舌で考えるんだって
あのシロちゃんが何考えてるか分からない
関西の方に知ってる犬がいてね
まあもうおしんこ食べる
まあ人間食べるものならもう何でも食べるという
そこはもうわからないね
好き嫌いっていうことにはね
とにかく生命には好き嫌いがあります
それは心の感情で だから心によって
それで体は変化していくんです
だからこの仏教では衆生がいるんであって
もう一切衆生は完璧に男女に分けてるわけじゃないんだと
みんな生命であって そこでもう転生している過程で
それでそれで性別を取っちゃうんだと
例えば人間が死んでミミズになってしまったら
男ですか女ですかね ミミズは両性だからね
カタツムリも両性だから
だから両性の動物もいるんだからね
そこで両性のミミズがどんどん転生して人間になるとどちらになるのかと
で そういうことで やっぱり心にはこの出てくるこの好き嫌いの感情によって性別を成り立つのです
それで男でも女でも修行して瞑想して禅定作っちゃうと
もう天界を飛ばしちゃって梵天に生まれるんですね
梵天は欲がない次元なんです
梵天の一番下のレベルからトップ上まで
あの最高位までも もう性欲がない世界次元
そちらで男の梵天と女の梵天が生まれちゃうと
もう意味がないんですね
そういう欲はもともと持ってないんでしょうし
ですから梵天になるとみんな男性にしているんです
これは私から考えれば
別にもう梵天だから 男性か女性かという考え方も意味がないんですけど
まあ何か性区別しなくちゃいけないっていうことで
アビダンマの世界が困っちゃって
まあ生命だから まあこの性の区別しなくちゃいけないんですね
まあ男性にしちゃいちゃいちゃいましょうということではないかなと思いますけどね
で 要するにしていて それでもう何光年も
もうもうもう大体もう短くても 1万光年だからね
寿命は 光っていうのは光ではなくて
あの仏教でいうカッパという意味でね
だからまあこれ 1万光年も最低でもそちらにいてね
それでまた人間に あるいは神の次元にもう下がるでしょうし
禅定の力が消えちゃったんだから
下がる場合はどうするのかと
その場合は過去で の性になるんだと
あの間ではそういう好みは全くない
好き嫌いはない 長い間ありましたけど
そこで次元切れちゃうと
まあ元のところからまた始まりますよということで
また元にいた生に戻るんだと
修行した時の それでこの人の性区別っていうのは確定していないんだよっていうことは
仏教はかなり厳しく言っているんです
だからかなり気をつけて
注意深く道徳を守って生活しなくちゃいけないんです
だから 淫らな行為は良くないっていうのは
もういろんな面で とにかくもうこの半端な性的な気持ちっていうのは
結構不幸を招くんです
だから女ならものすごいしっかりした女で
もう安全 楽ですよ 精神的に何の問題もなく
男ならしっかりした男なら何の問題もなく
もう社会はうまくスムーズに活動する
これ好き嫌いはもう中途半端で曖昧で
もうガタガタで もうあれこれということになっちゃうと
もうまあ命としてはうまくいかないんだっていうぐらいの話で
だからまあそこら辺はちゃんと道徳
仏教は道徳的なところだけポイントを入れますから
とにかく誰であろうともちゃんと道徳を守りなさいと
それはもうどうしようもないことであると
道徳破るっていうことはね
まあそういうことで 男であろうとも
自分が男やと威張っちゃうとひどい目になっちゃうし
女は女でそこで威張っちゃうとかなり不幸にはなることはなります
とにかくあの 何と言うんですか
このすごい恐ろしい考え方あるでしょう？あの女たちの
あれ 何と言いますかね
フェミニズム  フェミニズム
私はあれは危ないなと思いますけどね
どちらでも良くないんですよ
男性のチョイニズムという男性の場合
何て言いますかね  ましょうね
女性主義とか マチズモとか
ショビニズムと言いますけどね
だからこれは結構ありましたけどね
まあまあ全部このヨーロッパなことで
私たちにガチャガチャ文句言われたっても意味がないんですけどね
あの連中は何か問題作ってこちらにぶっかけるんだから
で こちらの阿呆どもたちもそれに乗ると
その西洋の思考に乗るたびに
私はもう完璧なアホだと思いますよ
だってこちらにもこちらの思考生き方あるんだから
例えば中国で昔はね もうかなり女性の立場が悪かったでしょうに
それを中国人は自分なりにもう全部変わってるんです今は
別にヨーロッパ人の考え方に乗ったわけじゃないんです
もう徹底的に平等ですね
ヨーロッパとは全く関係なく
中国人の間でフェミニズムの話なんか聞いたことはないんです
で そういうことだから
チョイニズムであろうがフェミニズムであろうがね
こんなに威張るもんかと
威張るべきもんかとね
それ自体もすごい差別的な考え方で怒りでしょうしね
ではなくて すごく冷静に物事を考えて
不公平っていうことはしっかりともうなくなるようにと努力し続けていけばいいんです
この億万長者の息子人が
この大阿羅漢に対してアヨーニソ チッタン ウッパーデットワ
やってはいけない気持ちを抱いたところで
アヨーニソっていうのはもう
一応ヨーニソというのはありのままに
あるのごとくっていうことで
アヨーニソというのはその反対で
ですからこの長老もいくらものすごい美しい体を持っていたとしても男でしょうし
この人も男でしょうし
だから男同士でかっこいい男だなと思ったらそれでよかったのに
それはもう男同士でもすごい体格がいい人のこと気になりますよ
俺があの体なんかね どうしようもないんだとというふうに思ったりはするし
そこでお互いに体を成長していくですとか
もう男の子供たちっていうのは
もうお兄ちゃんたちに憧れるでしょうね
それでもう力ついてやるぞと言って頑張って頑張って
あれこれスポーツやったり
いろんなことやったりして
まあそこはもう同じ性同士での互いを見ながら見ながら
自分たちも一人前になろうというのは
そういう風に考えるのは自然であって
女は女同士で人の体は気になるわ
それで自分を磨いていくでしょうね
それだったらようにそうですけど
普通の自然的なものなんですけど
これはもう逆になってしまったんですね
だから もうこれは侮辱なんで
例えばもうすごいひどい言葉で言えば
もうあのダイア羅漢に対してカッチャーナ長老に対して何か言ったわけじゃないんだけど
あんたは女になった方がいいんじゃないかなというような言い方なんですね
言ったならば それではえらい侮辱でしょうね
口では言ってないんだけど
女の体みたい 本当になんて美しいでしょうかと言っちゃうと
これは男としてものすごいプライドが傷つくんですよ
かなりやられちゃうと思いますよ
殴られる可能性はものすごいあります
だから これが明らかにものすごい聖者を侮辱したことで
口で何も言ってない しかし
心で思うことは一番重罪なんですよ
そういうことをして すぐ即座にその結果を得てしまったと
それ業の法則とってね
人に お前なんか女になった方がいいやと怒鳴っちゃうと
相手が女になるわけじゃなくて自分がなるんです
罰当たると人に言っちゃうと
自分がその気持ち抱いたんだから自分になるんです
実際もう起きて起きますよ
それはいくらでも証拠あります
で 結構私はそういう人々の態度やらね
それから出てくる結果やらね
結構チェックしたところで
相手になってほしいというものは全部自分になってしまうんです
だからカンバスも幸福になってほしいと
幸せでいてほしいということは徹底的に思いなさいと
その気持ち持ちなさいというのは
もう人々のためを思って言っていることなんです
だから お前なんか死んでしまえとすごい怒りで言うと
相手の命を侮辱しているんですね
尊厳を侮辱しているんですよ
生命は生き続けたいんだからね
死にたくないんだから
それで自分の尊厳が侮辱されるんです
自分の寿命が短くなるんです
死んでしまえと言ったら死んでしまう羽目になるんです
これはもう業の法則で
誰にもどうすることもできないことで
なぜならば 自分の心の気持ちですから
自分の心の気持ちによって
次の次の次の出来事は起きてしまうんです
だからもう幸せでありますようにという言葉しか安全な言葉が人間にないんです
だから これは最大のお守りとしてしているんです
最高な最大なお守りの言葉っていうのは
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
そういう気持ちが掃除機だったら
ものすごい強力で もう信じられないほど幸福な生き方が成り立つんです
それでこの人がもう女になって
もうタクシーラというね
ところに行って それでまあ
結婚したか お嫁さんになったかどうかわかりませんけど
向こうは何人もお嫁さんもらえますからね
そのある金持ちの家に入ってしまって
結局妊娠するんですよ
それで子供２人産むんですよ ２
回妊娠して それでこの人に前
自分がソーリヤという街にいたんだからね
結婚していたんです その時も子供２人がいたんです
子供４人いるんです そこに時間が経ったところで
ある日このソーリヤ町からも商人のカラバンがタキシラという風に行ったんですね
こちら商人商売をやっている人だから
一応それでまあ関係はあって
この今女性ですけどね
それでまあ人見たところで
自分が商売やっていた町の人だから
これは結構知っている
昔の商売仲間だから それでその人を家に呼んで
ものすごいこの接待したみたいですね
ものすごい贅沢なの そしたら 「
私は奥さんだからね 奥さん知らないし
会ったこともないし なのに
なんで私にそんなにも
もう接待してくれるんですか」と
そしたら 「 私はあなたのこと知ってますよ」と
そしたらこの商人が「ありえないんだ」と
これすっごい離れてる街で
国も違いますからね 「
ありえないんだ」と そしたら「もうあなたはなになにさんではないか」と 「
あなたの家はここではないか」とかね
そこでその情報は全部言うんです
それで全部もうその通りで 「
だから知ってますよ」と
どうやって知ってるのかと
これ不思議でたまらないんですね
こんなに家の中のことまでね
この商人の家族のことやらね
言って 「もうそういう
あの人どうですか？この人どうですか？元気でしょうか」とか
一人一人人々のことを聞く
それで それでこの それ家のこの一番金持ちの家な
こちらはね 設定という位が持っているんだからね 「
あの家どうですか？」と 「
みんな元気でやってますよ 」
それで あの その家の二人がいたんですけど 「
長男どうなってるんでしょうか？」と聞いたんです 「
あれだけは聞くなよ」と 「
その人のことは」と 「
どういうことでしょう」と言ったら
まあ言うんですね 「突然亡くなった」と
家の長男が商売やってた人が突然亡くなって
もう大変なことで 探しても探しても見つからないし
それでまあもう亡くなったということにして
もうもう一応今落ち着いているんだと
言ったら 「ああそうですか
本当はね それ私ですよ
その人は」と 言ったら 「
冗談おっしゃらないでください」と
あの方はこの天使のような
ものすごい美しい男でしたと
そちらはもう正真正銘の女性でしょう
奥さんでしょうと そこでまあ
彼女がこのどうなったかという出来事をその人に言ったんですね
本当はこんなことを聞いてしまったと
マハカッチャーナ長老見て変なことを考えちゃって
そこでこの商人の方がもうそちらはとんでもない罪を犯してしまったと
マハカッチャーナ長老にそんなこと思ったんですと
ひどい目に遭ったでしょうと
この罪をちゃんと謝らなきゃいけないんだと
大長老に 「私は謝りたいんだけど
マハカッチャーナ長老っていうのはもうどうやって会いますか」と 「
大丈夫ですよ」と マハカッチャーナ長老も本当はここら辺に今もう旅ですから
お坊さんたちはね いるんだと
それでこの托鉢に出たら
托鉢行った家でご飯もらったらそのまま帰りますから
自分の家まで来るか来ないかとかわからないし
そこは何とかしなくちゃいけないんだから
もうもうなんとか協力してくださいと言ったところで
で これ女性だからね まあ簡単に家は出られないし
で この男性の人がよくわかりましたと言って
このカッチャーナ長老のところに行ってもうお布施しますということで約束するんです
したら あんたね もう客でしょうと
この街ではね と断ろうとしているんですね
と言ったら まあ長老は私は客であるとかね
そんなことは気になさらないでくださいと
とにかく私の接待を受けてくださいと
で それ長老がそこをいいということにして
あの家に行ったんですね
とにかく そこで彼女は恥ずかしくて言えないんですね
これこんなことを思ったということさえも
それで この自分の前のね
この友人の商人の人がその家に呼んで
そこで彼女はもう奥さんでも全部料理作ってお布施をして
そしたらこのとにかくお布施は男性がするような感じなんです
男性の方が長老の招待して連れてきてもらって
それでこの家で食事をさせてあげてる
いつでもこの 仏教で在家と言うんですけど
この在家の格をこの男性の商人がやっているんです
言ったらこの まあ長老
私のこのこのお姉ちゃん
何て言いますか 許してあげてくださいと
これが私のものすごい仲のいい友達でしたと
この方はね しかし 長老を見て
こんな変なことを考えちゃって
こんな風になってしまったと
今は そこで長老が話を聞いたところで
ああそう じゃあカマミという言葉を言ったんですね
カマミっていうのはこの許しますというね
その言葉 長老のお口から出た瞬間で
また再び 男になってしまったんです
そこでとにかく大変なことになりまして
もう男になったんですけど
自分が産んだ子供２人もいるんですね
そうすると みんなもうまあこれはしょうがないということで
まあでも自分が一応今は男ですけど
自分が産んだ子供ですから
まあ子供と一緒にいてくださいと
子供の面倒を見てくださいと
そしたらこの人がもう頭がおかしいと
自分の 私は前男で 自分には子供２人がいるんだと
父親として こちらに来ると母親としても２人がいるんだと
私はもう男やと もうこんなことでももうもうもうもうこりごりやと
だからあなたの子供でしょうと
一応父親がいるんだから
あんたこの２人の面倒見なさいよと
私はもう誰の家にも戻れませんよと
このまま出家するんだよと言って
カッチャーナ長老のところでまた弟子にして出家しちゃったんです
とにかくそれでまあ旅に出て
このサイジョンの方にまた出家したらあっちこっち行くんだから
サイジョンに戻ったんです
戻ったらこの話はもうどこにでも知られてしまって
みんな大変大騒ぎ もう信じられない話ですからね
とにかく当時の人々にも
みんな聞いて ああ そんな出来事あったってこと本当ですかと
それと まあ別に本当ですよと
これでみんな知りたがっているのは別なことなんですね
みんなどちらが知りたがっていると思いますかね
いろんな根掘り葉掘り聞くんですけどね
このついで みんなまあじゃあじゃあ推測してみてください
人々はいろいろ聞いて
もう珍しい信じられない話ですから
長老が見るともうまたその話を聞く
男の時が幸せですか？女の時が幸せですか？ １つは提案が出ました
推測だから またいろいろあるでしょう
逆はできないんですか？ ん？ 逆はできないんですか？ 逆って？ いや
だから あの 男から女に変わっちゃったけど
ん？ 男から女に変わっちゃったけど
女から男に変わることはできないんですか？ それはちょっと推測としては投げ方ないね
それはその長老に聞いたって
[笑い] 全然乗り切り
自分が男性であったってことがもう乗り切り忘れて捨てたんですか？忘れていったんですか？違和感がなかったんですか？ まあ
それは違和感があったんだからね
あの それはあまり  まあまあ
まあ違和感があったことは確かで
恥ずかしくて逃げ出したし
また町のね 人が見ただけでものすごい話し合ってね
まあ寂しくて寂しくてね
自分の前の人生はね みんな
まあなかなかね だからみんなにしてみれば
この人は人生二つ生きてるんですね
女性の人生と男性の人生二つ生きている
だからいろいろ聞きたいことがあるんです
その中でもみんな一番聞きたいことがあったんです
男性の方が男性として生きた方が得だったか
女性として生きた生きていた得だとこら
そんな  後ろの方に何か意見ないんですかね
いいですか えっと あの
性格は変わりましたか？あの心
気持ちとか あのものの見方や考え方が男から女になったとか
そういう性格だったそういうのは変わったのか
はい もう一つ推測ないんですか
どちらの方がいいですか
同じ質問のことですからね
それは はい 若い人々はどう思いますかね
私が聞いているのは このみんな根掘り葉掘り聞くんだけど
ある一つはみんなどうしてもこれは知りたいということがあったんだ
それは何でしょうかと
いいですか  うん  あの男だった時には女が魅力的に見えたと思うんですけど
女になった時に男を魅力的に見えましたか？ うん
いや あの  妊娠したらどんな感じがあるんですか？ うんうん
なるほど まあいろいろ意見
まあじゃあ一応それぐらいにしましょう
なかなかアイデアインスピレーションというのはなかなか出てこないんだからね
妄想できるだけやめてくださいね
[笑い]いくらでも頭は
体験します で 例えばこの今妊娠した時はどんな感じでしょうか？という質問ね
それはそんなに根掘り葉掘り聞かなくてもいいんだよ
女に聞けば いくらでもいるんだからね
男がそういうふうな感覚でどう翻訳するかっていうのが
女がそう言っても男は
そう言ったっても相手が別人だから
妊娠したらどんな感じですかと聞くのは男でしょうね
だからそれはその人に聞いたって
他の女の人に聞いたって同じことなんですよ
だからしっかりした うん
これどちらが重要性ですか？という推測あるんですね
やっぱり大体みんなの推測はまあその程度なんですよ
で 当時のこの人々はよくよく聞いたのはそれじゃないんです
あなたは子供２人産んだんだよと
それで子供２人の父親だよと ４
人もあんたの子供ですね
どちらの方が一番気になってるんでしょうかと
どちらの方がすごい心配してたまらないんでしょうかと
それ聞いたんです それでしょう
聞かなくちゃあかんのは
これもうありえない話で
女の気持ちは何でしょうかと女に聞けばわかるし
男の気持ちは何でしょうかと男に聞けばわかるし
で 好みは何でしょうかと
女の好みは何でしょうかと女に聞けば言うし
男の好みって何でしょうかと女男に聞けば言うし
そんなのは世間の常識でみんな知ってるでしょうに
だって男の女の気持ちが分かったければ
男はね 女読んでる雑誌やら本やら漫画やら読めば簡単にわかるでしょうに
現に日本の女性はね もう男読むものは堂々と読んでるでしょうね
私もどんな精神性格かとちょっと驚いたりしますけど
でもどちらかというと
男って何考えてるのかと
雑誌見たらすぐわかるでしょうね
男が見る雑誌だったら
もうほとんど裸の写真ばっかしてもう何もない
もう宣伝があったら車の宣伝ぐらいとかね
女の雑誌見たらもうおしゃれと食い物の話ばっかしで
だからまあそれぐらいのことっていうのはもう普通にわかりますよ
しかし 父親の気持ちと母親の気持ちはね
どう差があるのかっていうことが
それ聞きたかったんです
で 私はこれちょっと一つ試してみたんです
皆様を 別に正しい推測なくてもいいんですよ
正しい答えなくても 推測によって自分の興味見えてくるんですよ
だから結局はみんな自分のことしか言わなかったでしょ
これはこの悲しいことなんで
文明社会はね 我々仲間で一緒に生活しているんだということで
このみんなのことを気になる
心配するということはないというね
それは私は調べたかっただけ
見事にハメられて ハメてしまいました
そういうことおっしゃる方
漫才 質問やら何やら余計出にくくなると思いますよ
常に試されるってことは
みんな分かってて承知の上で言ってることもあるかもしれないです
だからそれは勉強ということなんです
そういうことで起きています
で やっぱりこの我々は今
すごい人工的な不自然な社会を作って生きているんですよ
だから思考さえも不自然なんですよ
だから全ての生命と一緒に生きているんだから
私は何食ってるのかということよりも
みんなどう生きているのか
みんな元気でしょうかというポイントはすごく大事なんです
これで子供育てる女性にしたっても
自分の子供のことだけ気になるんであって
不自然なんですよ だからみんないろんな問題を起こしたり
トラブルを起こしたりはしている
普通は女が子供を産んだらもう母になるんであって
母でいえばもう母なんですよ
結構大胆になるはずなんですよ
結構人格はしっかりするはずなんです
子供を産んで育てて もう手塩にかけて育てて大人にしちゃえば
これかなり自信満々あるはずなんですが
今ないんです だから我々も原始社会で生きてるんだから
女は本当に怖いんですよ
怖いっていうのは 日本でいう意味の怖さじゃないんですよ
あの迫力とあのリーダーシップにはもう全くもう何もできません
誰にでも嫌なことだとあんた何をと言うんです
それでなんでそれ通じるのかというと
ただ田舎のおばあちゃんでも
すごい立派な人になっちゃっても
言いたいことはすぐ言う
しかしみんなあ そうですか
分かりましたと即座に認める
それがただうるさい女だから
ババだからうるさいって意味じゃないんです
自分が母親だからという態度なんです
私は母親だから言った途端
我々はやっぱり生命のことは心配しているんだと
こちらのためを思って言ってるんだと
だから上からは言えるところじゃないやと
ここは下がるしかないやと
相手が誰であろうか 何のことなく
もう例えばすごい凶暴な乱暴な男でも
喧嘩したりでも女が出ていくんですよ
お前いい加減にしないかと
家に帰れと言っちゃうと
いくら興奮状態でいたっても
何のことなく家に帰るんです
自分の奥さんでなくても大丈夫です
自分の母親でなくても大丈夫です
家に帰れと怒鳴っちゃうと
もう自分の家ではほとんど男同士いろんな喧嘩になってくると
やっぱりもう女が出ていくんです
男がじゃあやっつけるぞと
これは出ていかない でも
例えば自分の家の前で兄弟とすごい喧嘩しちゃうと
もう家で男がいたっても
俺が行っちゃうともっとひどくなるんだから
お前行って何か言いなさいよと女を出すんです
それが母たる力なんですよ
それがやっぱり経済的に発展して
もう金しか頭がなくなっちゃって
何を買うかと もうもうルイヴィトン買うかシャネル買うかということにまで人が堕落しちゃうと
その本来我々持っている生きる喜びと力が消えてしまうんです
もう本当に生きることというのは
まあ大変楽しく気楽で生きていられますよ
それを失ってしまうんですね
そういうことが言いたかったんです
で 私も子供の頃 このエピソードを随分小さい頃聞いたんですけど
聞いた時って その時も私も同じ質問家になっちゃったんですね
だから自分には父親と母親がいるんだから
自分のことを一番心配しているのは誰でしょうかと
その場合 自分のことでしたけど
これでこのこの長老が何答えたと思いますか？子供二人がいて
誰のことを一番可愛いというか
心配というかね そんなのは聞かない
答え決まってるんです
聞いたらまた何か言われると言うんだからね
で この長老が 私が産んだ子供の方が一番気になるんだと
一番心配して一番可愛いと感じるのは
どちらかというとやっぱり自分が産んだ子供だと
こんなのは当たり前のことで
男にっていうのはもう母親が「これはお前の子供や」と言わない限りは実感ないでしょうに
女はバカだから まあ子育ては一人でできるものじゃないんです
まあ女とはバカもんだからね
もうこれは自分で全部やろうと思って
ものとんでもない感情で
執着で わがままで 自分の所有物にするんですよ
それは要りません それは良くない
正しくないんです 子供を産んだ途端
もう男の体にぶん殴った方がいいんです
あんた育てなさいよと
あなたの子供だよと 言って
あれこれと仕事を頼んだ方がいいんです
オムツ替えることやらお風呂に入れることやら
夜泣いちゃうと もうもう抱っこしてあげることやら
でももういくら文句言っても
文句言っちゃうと怒鳴ってね
大変大変だ どうでも大変だと
だから私がやるんですか？とそうやって言っちゃうと
子供にも手がかかるんですね
男に それで自分の子供という感じが生まれてくるんです
自分が抱っこしてあっちこっち連れていくと
これは自分の子供だと守らなくちゃという
強烈に そこで初めて感情が湧いてくるんです
それで家族は安定するんですよ
お父さんとべったりだからといって
これで嫉妬するのはあんまりに不自然なんです
嫉妬するんだから 母親が
なぜあまり不自然かというと
いくらなんでも子供っていうのは産んだ人の方に行くんですよ
その愛情はもう確率だと
もう確定だと思ったところであっちこち遊び回ってるんです
それは決まってるんだと
それに嫉妬しちゃうと
ものすごく関係が崩れちゃうんです
ですから この女性は自分の体で育てるんだから
これは心から消えるものじゃないんですね
生まれたものの心から
だから男は体を貸してあげることと
女は体を貸してあげたことは随分違いますよ
全く比べるものにもならないんです
女は男は体貸すって ちょっと遊び相手になるぐらいの話でしょうに
やんちゃになってものすごくいたずらばかりやっちゃうと
男は体力あるんだから
それにはもう相手にしてあげたりする
それぐらいのことでも
女は体貸すっていうことは体貸すことだからね
命まで危ないことになるでしょう
おっぱいあげるってこと
自分の血液を飲ませてるんだから
これは全然もう話にならない
比べるものにならない
ですから わざと強引に愛情を作らなくちゃいけないんですよ
男の心に 強引に迷惑かけてやらないとうまくいかないで
これやらないんだから
結婚があって 家庭関係っていうのはうまくいってないんです
で この長老に聞いちゃうと
長老はこれは私が産んだ子供の方が一番可愛いと
いつでもこれ聞くんだから
ものすごくもうもうもううるさになったんですね
出家して人が来て 何々長老
あのその長老ですね なんとか
またその話になる これはもうやりきれんだからね
それからもうずっと人と顔を合わせないと
一人でいる 喋れませんとかね
そうやってまああの一人で生活することになったんですね
で まあそれから長老の心の転換というのは
いつでもどちらの方が一番可愛いでしょうか
どちらの方が一番気になるんですよと
この執着のことを聞いてるんだからね
やっぱり言うたびに自分が気持ち悪くなるんですよ
本当のこと言うんです
産んだ子供の方がもう随分気になるんだと
言うたびに気持ち悪くなっちゃうんですね
やっぱりそれでも これが執着やと
それで引っ掛けになって
まあ修行してものすごい大荒れになるんです
それで荒れ果てになってから
まだもうそれでまた黙ってる必要はないんですからね
で また人が同じことで聞くんだそうですね
だからどちらでも関係ないんだと
うるさいんだと 何の執着もないんだと
そちらは勝手にいればいいやと
気にしませんよということを言い始めたんです
それでお坊さんたちが
この人は前はね もう産んだ子供の方がやっぱり執着あるなと言っていて
今はまあどちらでも勝手にしろと言うんだからね
何か自分が煩悩がないということを言ってるんではないかということで
そんなことは煩悩はない
悟っているんだとか そんな勝手に言ってはあかんですよ
これはすごい大変な問題になるんです
それでお釈迦様はそれはその通りですよと
彼が本当のことを言ってるんだと
いうことで ちゃんと完全たる大荒れになってるんだと
でお釈迦様は言うんです